hey guys happy tech Tuesday today I'm
going to be checking out this is the
magnetic charging dock by Apple so this
is for the Apple watch and I'm kind of
excited about this because I didn't even
know that this was out so Apple being
your biggest number one fan how did I
not know this was something stay in
school kids I'll just use these nice
scissors that I used to cut my dog's
hair oh it's got like a little like a
little this is soft just room velvety
this is cool I was gonna say homey you
better give me one of these cords I can
never have enough lightning cables is
anything else in here knit I'm gonna get
up on this counter cuz I wanna show you
I suppose so this is cool because you're
able to charge it two different ways
this little guy pops right up peel this
little sticky off really nice it is
really nicely made and it looks good oh
you look good this one here - mm just
back up a little more uh my body back a
little more so there's a tiny little
lightning cable right there port in the
back plug her in like so and there's two
ways that you're able to charge your
Apple watch if you want to have it in
like the alarm clock mode you can charge
it this way and it just sticks there
real nicely or if you're just being all
basic and you just want to slap it down
pop that little guy down and pop this
down just like so the problem is this
was $80 $80 but if you think about it he
came with one of these cables which I
think in itself is probably 30 or 40
dollars ah
where'd I leave off oh I was trying to
justify the price of this it's pretty
well-made it's heavy so you're not going
to knock it off your nightstand but it
looks really good it's like a doughnut
oh my god does look like a doughnut I
would eat this I would definitely
definitely eat those this is like a
vanilla wafer
I think this top part feels like a nice
little leather this is a nice little
felt bottom give you a nice close-up
look at that look you over
look at this oh my Apple watch is so
beat-up thank you guys for watching I
hope you enjoyed the video let me know
if you guys have any suggestions for a
future tech Tuesday video you can leave
those in the comments below if you
joined this video or any of my videos
make sure you guys have the like button
and of course you can subscribe if you'd
like to see more videos